دق الأطباء ناقوس الخطر حول
انتشار المعلومات الخاطئة المرغوبة على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، وكتب الطبيبان اللذان توشك أن تسمع منهما
في صحيفة نيويورك تايمز أن
المعلومات المضللة على فيسبوك
تجعل وظائفهما أكثر صعوبة ، لذا دعونا
نتحدث إليهما
د كريغ سبنسر المدير  الصحة العالمية
والطب في المركز الطبي بجامعة
كولومبيا في نيويورك الدكتورة
سيما ياسمين المحلل الطبي ، شكرًا لكما ،
أنا سعيد جدًا
لأنكما هنا يا د.
زميل
ليس طبيبًا ولكن
شخصًا يعمل في إيه ، قال إن هناك
علاجًا للسرية 19 ،
لا يوجد علاج ، وعلى الرغم من أنه تم
عرض دليل يثبت أنه لا يوجد
علاج ، فقد قال ولكني رأيته على Facebook
أقصد وهو يعمل ، أعني تعال  حول مدى
عمق هذه
المعلومات بالطريقة التي تشبه
كل محادثة أجريها
مع شخص أعرفه من مؤيدي ترامب ،
فأنا معجب يا إلهي
ولكن استمر تشعر بالألم  لا يكون الأمر
محبطًا
للغاية وهناك مستوى آخر من
الخوف عندما يكون متخصصًا في الرعاية
الصحية وتعتقد أنه يجب عليك أن تعرف
جيدًا ، لكن هذه النقطة تصل حقًا إلى المنزل
دون
أن يكون كل شخص على مستوى ما
عرضة لهذه
المعلومات الصحية الخاطئة والمعلومات المضللة
لأن هناك  الكثير من الهراء لدرجة
أن الأشخاص الذين
يدفعون به
يستغلون حقيقة
أننا جميعًا ضعفاء حقًا في الوقت الحالي ،
نشعر بالقلق من أننا غارقون في
المعلومات التي لا نعرف ما
نصدقه  يقول الرئيس شيئًا
ما يقوله العلماء شيئًا آخر ،
إذن لديك منصات مثل Facebook
ومنصات التواصل الاجتماعي الأخرى ،
إنها تنشر هذه الأشياء بالفعل
وتستخدم الخوارزميات التي تكافئ
التفاعل مع المعلومات السيئة
لأن الأشياء المزعجة التي لا
معنى
لها عادة ما تكون خيالية أكثر بكثير  الكثير من الأشياء التي
لا تنسى والتي
تريد مشاركتها مقارنة
بنوع الحقائق الجافة المملة
التي تقدمها المؤسسة الطبية  يتم نشر التنبيهات ،
لذا فإن هذا التقرير الذي
صدر الأسبوع الماضي من منظمة
أفارز
يبحث في مقدار المعلومات المضللة والمعلومات
المضللة التي تنتشر على فيسبوك
، ووجدوا أنه في العام الماضي
حصلت هذه الأشياء على 3.8
مليار مشاهدة وأنا لست وحدي
كريغ من يستطيع
لم يواكبوا cdc و wato لا يمكنهم إما
وضع أشياء هناك على facebook
أيضًا المعلومات الجيدة التي
لا تصل إلى أي مكان بالقرب من العديد من الزيارات
والعديد من المشاهدات ، لذا فهو موقف
صعب حقًا ، نعم والناس
معرضون حقًا لذلك  لا سيما
الشباب الذين أجدهم مثل الشباب
مثل الأطفال في سن الجامعة الذين يستخدمون
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي كثيرًا
كما تعلمون أنهم قد يستمعون إلى
والديهم وقد يؤمنون
بكل هذه الأشياء وهذا
ليس صحيحًا على الإطلاق دكتور سبنسر
كم مرة تفعل  أسمع هذه الادعاءات الكاذبة
من مرضاك ، فأنا أسمعهم طوال
الوقت ، وللأسف ، لا يقتصر الأمر على
المرضى وليس فقط
الأشخاص على اليسار أو الأشخاص على
اليمين ، بل كل الأشخاص وهذا  لقد كان
جزءًا من المشكلة هو أن
هذا التقويض للصحة العامة
والعلوم منذ بداية هذا
التفشي وهذا الوباء في الولايات المتحدة
قد أدى إلى عدم معرفة الناس
إلى أين يذهبون ، حقيقة أننا لا
نملك cdc
خارج  أمام الجمهور كل
يوم لإخبارنا بالتحديثات التي تعطينا
نوعًا من المعلومات التي
يجب على الأشخاص الموثوقين العثور عليها على Facebook أو
يتعين عليهم العثور عليها في موجز تويتر الخاص بالرئيس ،
فهم لا يعرفون إلى أين يتجهون
للحصول على معلومات موثوقة  إنهم لا
يحصلون عليها
من فريق عمل cdc ، على سبيل المثال
، لم يحصلوا عليها من فريق
عمل chronovirus
الذي يبحثون عنه
ولسوء الحظ يجدونها في أماكن مثل
facebook
حيث تنتشر المعلومات المضللة الفيروسية
أسرع من الفيروس نفسه